I'm about to turn 30 so I'm gonna go
around the office and ask people what
they learned in their 20s don't date
comedians start taking care of your skin
early take the risk save your money
don't waste it on alcohol usually the
best things take the longest amount of
time to get to you the quicker that
something happens overnight usually the
less quality it is trust no one that
your brain really does not fully develop
until I'll raise you 26 because I'm
still figuring this out I really
like when plants are canceled how to
organize my money Finance for sure I
think to give myself Grace don't date
somebody that broke your heart more than
once don't sell yourself short eat like
while you still can and then your 30s
still do it but just try to get more
sleep